when the motive team came on board to
specifically do the single-player
campaign for Battlefront 2 we had our
team from Lucasfilm story group we had
our internal Lucasfilm games production
team we kind of all huddled and they
were like we have a pitch for you and
we're like cool let's see what this is
we knew when coming into battlefront
that we wanted to tell soldiers story
and you know we've seen a lot of stories
from the heroes of the rebellion they
pitched us a story that would span from
Return of the Jedi through to the events
of the force awakens one of the great
things that they included too was like
we want to do it from an imperial point
of view because it hasn't really been
been done at least not on a fidelity
before a new protagonist is ivan versio
she is a loyal member of the empire an
elite imperial pilot she comes from an
imperial family a father as an admiral
she is the perfect candidate to believe
in the good of the Empire
[Music]
something we really wanted to get into
in the story is it to kind of get inside
and meet the people inside the Empire so
it's not just a faceless stormtrooper
who's part of the Legion who all believe
in the same thing uniformly
stormtroopers and everyone inside the
Empire they aren't conscripted the
unforced they are brainwash on their own
program from from an early age to
believe and what we do with the audience
is we take them to a place where they
can understand the idol and why she
makes the decisions that she does
impossible there's some really great
character and gameplay moments right and
somebody who's on the development team
story is is really important to me and
we've all worked really hard to craft
something we're incredibly proud of and
so I'm excited for fans to get this game
in their hands to be able to play as I
did in Inferno squad and there's some
really cool single-player gameplay
moments that I'm excited for fans to get
their hands on
[Music]
great
you